après moscou et kiev emmanuel macron et
donc à berlin ce soir un président
français qui espère bien jouer le rôle
de médiateur dans la crise ukrainienne
on en parle avec un autre grand reporter
régis le sommier
bonsoir régissent le président français
mission que s'entretenir avec le
chancelier allemand il président
polonais ils sont d'ailleurs en train de
donner une conférence de presse commune
elle vient de débuter elle sera suivie
de discussions privées quels sont les
enjeux de cette nouvelle rencontre
aujourd'hui
alors il ya deux choses qui sont un
portrait importante dans cette rencontre
c'est d'abord le véritable marathon
diplomatique
auquel vient de se livrer emmanuel
macron donc on l'a dit à rencontre avec
vladimir poutine le emmanuel macron le
premier dirigeant occidental deux
premiers plus long à avoir rencontré le
président russe à s'être frotté je dirai
au président russe vous savez au bout de
cette longue table qu'on a vu hier dans
le but n'est pas vraiment de mettre le
convive à l'aise mais néanmoins emmanuel
macron a passé cinq heures avec vladimir
poutine il dit avoir obtenu de la part
du dirigeant russe des garanties qu'il
n'y aura pas d' escalade supplémentaire
dans la crise en tout cas que cette
escalade ne viendra pas du côté russe et
avoir des solutions concrètes pratiques
pour solutionner cette crise donc on
attend un petit peu parce que le il est
prévu et vite avant que vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron devaient se parler à
nouveau après justement l'épisode kiev
c'est à dire la rencontre d' emmanuel
macron avec le président hélas qui cette
fois qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui et
l'autre voilà l'autre volet et c'est là
où aujourd'hui l'épisode berlin est très
important puisque dans deux dans le même
temps olaf scholz le chancelier allemand
lui rentre tout juste de washington où
il a rencontré les dirigeants américains
évidemment
sur les mêmes thématiques sur la table
thématique de la crise ukrainienne d'une
certaine mesure on avait vu jusqu'à
présent l'europe un petit peu laissé de
côté vous savez que depuis le début de
cette crise c'est surtout la diplomatie
russe contre la diplomatie américaine
les commandes par les sont engagées
entre les deux et comment l'europe a eu
l'impression d'avoir été tenu à l'écart
bien avec cette nouvelle initiative
d'emmanuel macro et de son côté celle de
la fiole c'est également qui a joué sa
part en allant aux états unis on peut
penser quand même que l'europe on
reprend la main sur ce dossier un
dossier qui la concerne au premier plan
puisque s'il ya une guerre en en ukraine
c'est un peu comme s'il y avait une
guerre en europe à l'origine c'est une
conférence de presse extrêmement courte
beaucoup plus courte que celle d'hier
avec vladimir poutine puisqu'elle vient
de s'achever avant le disais quand même
des des
discussions privées la france la pologne
et l'allemagne se sont unis pour
préserver la paix en europe 1 voilà en
substance ce qui est ressorti de cette
conférence de presse est clair en tout
cas des entretiens avec olaf scholz lui
même de retour de washington avec
finalement quel message
alors où les fioles la question c'était
évidemment le fameux oléoduc de gaz nord
stream 2 vous savez qu'il n'est toujours
pas rentré en comment qui ne trouvera
pas au perreux opérant aujourd'hui il
n'y a toujours pas de gaz qui circulent
dans ce nouvel oléoduc et évidemment les
allemands ont laissé alors les allemands
sont divisés sur cette question on sait
que la fiole c'est beaucoup plus
pragmatique c'était le grand argentier
dans gala merkel qu'il a été vice
chancelier pendant une pendant des
années et par contre ça 5comment
ministre des affaires étrangères anna
lena berlocq qui fait partie du parti
des grünen est beaucoup plus hostile à
la russie mais beaucoup et a toujours
été d'ailleurs hostiles à la mise en
place de ce pipeline le nom de ce
pipeline c'est vous dire à quel point
cette affaire est extrêmement comment
brûlante c'est que il n'a même pas été
prononcé pendant sa conférence de presse
par olaf scholz aux états unis donc
évidemment ça a été l'enjeu des
questions 2 comment des discussions avec
les américains les américains essayant
de faire pression pour les armes sur les
allemands de dire que si la russie
envahi l'ukraine et bien jamais ce pipe
line ne sera mis en action et donc ça
c'est un enjeu économique un enjeu
stratégique également d'une grande
importance pour l'allemagne est donc là
il ya eu effectivement les allemands
qu'on a senti au début de cette crise
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus sur la
réserve par exemple que l'otan ou que
les etats-unis vis-à-vis de la russie
principalement à cause de ces questions
de relations
entre au sujet des hydrocarbures entre
la russie et l'allemagne merci beaucoup
régis le sommier alors je vous le disais
cette conférence de presse entre les
dirigeants polonais et allemands et
français vient de s'achever suivi
maintenant par des discussions privées
donc à berlin lors plus tôt dans la
journée